you did do a oneoff with Russ yeah which
I thought was awesome uh we talked about
this a bit in the Vlog we did when I
went to your house um for people who
don't know who didn't see that Vlog you
did a one one deal album with Russ you
were still dropping tons and tons and
tons cuz Russ is the most artist
friendly guy ever and he just wanted to
be down you know yeah um but he had gone
on his tour
and he had offered you to come and open
on the tour and you turn that down yeah
most people would hear that I think me
and hovain talked about it when it
happened God Rest hovain soul rest in
peace to my brother um most people would
love to go on a tour with Russ and open
up cuz he was doing like Arenas and like
amphitheaters and stuff at that moment
cuz this was two three years ago 2021 so
yeah so this was two years ago22 yeah
this was the sh the snow globe album
yeah
um most people would jump at that uh
opportunity I know why you didn't do it
I kind of want you to explain cuz You'
built so much since then but I want you
to explain why you passed on that
opportunity man it would have took me
away from home and I was building
something I really really really
believed in at home and I knew that per
yeah you know and I knew the opportunity
to go on tour was Circle back and I
didn't um
I didn't I didn't really want to go on
tour and get a salary like I could go do
shows and make my own paper so I really
just wanted to stay home and build and I
end up building the backyard residency
in the perlet and that [__] end up
making me I mean 10x what I would have
generated on that tour and new fans new
meeting new everything you feel me so
I'm I'm happy I stayed home it was like
yeah cuz you would have got new fans
that way but you I don't know if you
would have gotten the amount of like
super engaged fans that you got by just
doing the cultural like it it just the
backyard is different you know like the
backyard is different and what what I'm
doing in terms of culture like you go in
my comments and you see the Buster
Rhymes and the ogs in there because they
know what's up like we ain't seen hipop
look like this in a minute and and I
think one of the last times you might
have saw it looked like this probably
was in your area I feel like when I
think of independent sh I think of Texas
I think of No Limit and I think of the
bay out the trunk you know what I'm
saying for sure uh is your
house because this is your your family's
house this is the house that you know
you grew up in at what point in time
does your Fame does your home
become inhabitable because of how
popular you are cuz for people who don't
know your house is in it's in a normal
neighborhood yeah there's no like crazy
there's no security there's it's just
your house right this is a normal house
that you grew up Ino California there's
stage in the backyard there I mean your
parents are there you got to get to a
point where is it a you going to end up
moving out of the house or getting the
parents out of there renting it out or
has it not gotten there yet I doubt I
mean we don't know how big it's going to
be yet Drake hasn't came to the backyard
just yet you know when Drake and Sh of
right now as of right now no we good man
my house is protected and it's like I'm
really from where I'm from like this is
my home I walk every day around the
block and everybody like I'm from there
I I hoop there I play tennis my daughter
we we like I'm I'm home no I no I get it
I get it but like again if once you get
to a certain point you're just going to
have random people flying to the Bay
being like yo let's go drive by the
Russell's house and see yeah yeah we had
a [__] come in uh from Buffalo and it
was his first time ever been on the
plane and he was like man I just had to
come see it and see if it was real so
yeah it's like did he knock on the door
no he just kind of drove past and said I
think he end up messaging us cuz he had
brought like some merch and I went
outside and I holled at him and I was
like man this isn't okay but I [__] with
you when I see I get it I understand
like man I I'm a human and I know how it
feel to have somebody that really
changed your life like this man was in
his 30s and it was his first time ever
getting on a flight cuz he was like I
have to go to that back [__] crazy
flight Buffalo there's no direct flight
don't there's no direct flight yeah
you feel me so I I understand that that
energy and when I was growing up in a V
I never seen nobody famous like I never
seen anyone who made it where I was like
ah I get to witness you know I didn't I
didn't get that experience so when I be
mobing around and I'm outside like I get
it I understand